[Musique]
Jonathan Trudeau à la question quai
bonsoir
bonsoir J'ai une enseignante qui m'écrit
dit oui vous êtes naïf le programme est
très chargé aux primaires
donc certains enfants habitent à 500
mètres de l'école vient en voiture
viennent en voiture avec les parents
donc les parents aussi ne
responsabilités faire bouger les enfants
bon mais je vais rester avec cette
vision naïve une heure pour tous les
enfants du Québec jusqu'à 17 ans mais
c'est pas je voulais pas vous faire
commenter ça vous pourrez sinon mais
Eric Duhem
Eric Duhem on va l'écouter qui a reçu la
réponse de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale en disant non il y aura pas de
lieu aménagés de passe droit en écoute
monsieur duvet
si on veut encourager les gens à voter
aux prochaines élections c'est pas en
faisant comme Madame Leroy qui monsieur
Legault le convoi réussir au contraire
ce qu'ils vont faire ces gens-là c'est
accentuer le fait que la participation
électorale est en chute libre au Québec
pour Jonathan est-ce que la présidente
avait une marge de manœuvre comment il
faut comprendre ça
il y a à faire avec votre commentaire
sur La sédentaire des jeunes clairement
rituels va avoir beaucoup de temps pour
bouger parce qu'il passera pas de
longues heures assises à son bureau à
l'Assemblée nationale car il n'aura pas
accès à la salutationale mon point de
vue là-dessus Patrice c'est
qu'effectivement la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale avait très peu de
marge de manœuvre en fait elle n'en
n'avait pas celle doit suivre les règles
existantes mais ça prend une
représentation elle elle fait à faire
avec des gens qui sont élus à
l'Assemblée nationale selon des règles
qui sont claires elle doit se gouverner
en conséquence et Éric Zem n'a pas fait
élire je pense qu'il faut davantage se
retourner vers les quatre autres parties
qui auraient plus l'heure des fameuses
négociations pour établir les budgets
les temps de parole et tout ça donner un
minimum d'accès irréductuel parce qu'il
faut bien se le dire on peut ne pas être
fan des rituels c'est demain on était
loin d'être irraisonnable d'avoir un
petit bureau d'être capable de faire un
point de frêle d'un point de presse
d'assister certaines séances de greffage
il demandait quand même pas la lune je
pense qu'au davantage de tourner par la
partie politique pour constater qu'il y
a une fermeture peut-être excessive
je pensais aussi qu'on trouverait
certains aménagements bon dans le cas du
bureau et des budgets soit je savais que
c'était pas mal exclu il y a pas d'élus
donc à un moment donné des limites à
faire de la place dans
l'enseignementaire un parti qui n'a pas
fait élire de député mais bon accès à
des points de presse peut-être qu'on
peut s'arranger avec la tribune la
presse que tout intérêt à garder Eric
dumm pas trop loin la tribu de la presse
était souveraine dans qui elle donne
accès à ces à ces bureaux ou assez
locaux pour donner des points de presse
peut-être que ça il pourrait y aménager
quelque chose mais pour les séances
d'information à huis clos en privé comme
le budget ça je suis assez étonné parce
que et tout un paquet d'économistes déjà
qui participent au huis clos du budget
les médias aussi qu'on a pas pu trouver
un aménagement assez simple pour Éric
dum pour qu'il soit plus au courant de
ce qui se passe pour améliorer ses
propres commentaires à l'issue d'un
débat par exemple sur le budget
semble-t-il que c'était pas une mauvaise
idée donc peut-être qu'on aurait pu
envoyer un message en disant que les
ministères pourraient arranger quelque
chose mais visiblement Nathalie Roy pas
voulu aller là donc je suis un peu à
faire
de ma compréhension Nathalie Roy a dit
que sur les brefages par exemple du
budget il en tenait effectivement il en
revenait au ministère finalement de
disposer de cette question là donc
est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir ouverture
c'est à suivre mais une fois qu'on a
tout dit ça sur l'accès l'Assemblée
nationale il faut quand même se dire
qu'il aime n'a pas tout perdu il donne
un peu l'impression qu'au lendemain
d'élection malgré près de 500 000
Québécois qui ont voté pour lui qu'il
n'a aucun moyen ben il faut pas oublier
que le financement des partis politiques
est en grande partie publique et établi
en fonction du nombre de votes donc Eric
duem joue un peu le martyre mais c'est
plus d'un million l'un des points
quelques millions qui va avoir par année
pour les quatre prochaines années ça lui
donne quand même amplement de moyens
pour deux ce verset un salaire on a vu
que l'exécutif du parti a entériné un
salaire de 130 000 $ par année et d'être
capable aussi d'organiser des activités
de communication relativement efficace
mais s'il fallait faiblesse situation
actuelle des cinq parties d'honneur pour
une autre élection on mesure à quel
point il y a pas de carte entière pour
ce genre de situation là au Québec ce
n'est pas fait pour 5 parties il faut
qu'il y en a un qui meurt le quand il y
en a qui meurent pas puis qui qu'on
reste c'est là qu'on le voit alors on
est dans ses discussions là depuis
toutes ces semaines Jonathan à cause de
ça
absolument et ça là-dessus moi je
continue de trouver que c'est absolument
déplorable que le gouvernement soit
fermé comme une nuit être le avoir une
discussion là-dessus on peut ne pas
aimer le résultat actuel mais il a été
il a été atteint en fonction de règles
sont bien établies donc maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire pour
changer les règles et en disant cela
soyons moi je suis bien clair je ne suis
pas je n'ai pas une opinion très
tranchée sur le fameux mode de scrutin
proportionnel mixte par contre je suis
d'avis que il y a lieu d'avoir la
discussion d'avoir un débat de consulter
les Québécois sur ce qui est de plus
étalé essentiel c'est-à-dire notre
démocratie la façon d'élire les gens qui
nous représentent je trouve ça dommage
que la lumière de cette distorsion là le
gouvernement soit fermé à voir avant la
discussion parce que l'entre deux Alex
si c'est un entre deux politiques vers
un repositionnement on verra
l'entre-deux il dure il va durer
quelques années quand même
dans une réforme parlementaire aplanir
les différents après ça a changé le mode
de scrutin l'espèce de reconnaissance
d'un parti officiel à 12 députés 20% des
voix ça tient plus on aurait un peu
trouver de manière à avoir une souplesse
ou on n'est pas en train de négocier à
chaque fois après une élection ça irait
comme on le vu on devrait avoir un
protocole en place qui soit beaucoup
plus simple qui soit plus respectueux
aussi peut-être justement avec le type
de demande qui est rituel en fait qu'on
généralise ça ça pourrait se retrouver
avantageux pour d'autres parties aussi
qui ont 15 16 % des voix pas de députés
c'est pas juste le code du Parti
conservateur éventuellement qui pourrait
être qui pourrait être dans cette
situation là donc on devrait les parties
devraient commencer à discuter de ça
tout de suite avant les prochaines
élections
mais on en doute ok
il y a un contrat qui concerne la GRC
qui a été donné une entreprise qui
appartient maintenant à des intérêts
chinois totalement je fais entendre
réactions et même monsieur Trudeau qui
savait plus trop quoi dire ce qui était
pas très content on le comprend on
écoute
comment ça se fait qu'on a qu'on engage
un entreprises qui est accusé
criminellement d'espionnage d'empêcher
l'espionnage dans nos forces policières
rentrez le proverbial renard dans le
proverbial poulailler de donner accès
aux codes des systèmes de sécurité les
plus intimes de l'État canadien et ni le
Premier ministre ni la GRC non jugé
pertinent de recevoir les signaux
d'alerte venus de Chicago ou de prendre
une alternative sécuritaire à propriété
canadienne
nous allons avoir deux questions pour
pour la fonction publique d'abord
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire immédiatement
pour sécuriser l'intégrité de nos
communications par rapport à la GRC et
autres instances que nous avons mais
aussi comment ce qu'on va s'assurer
qu'on arrête de signer des contrats avec
des compagnies qui ne sont pas fiables à
ce niveau-là
pas être plus clair lundi au
fonctionnaire qui ont fait ça vous avez
pas réfléchi avec
parlant de naïveté Patrice c'est
peut-être le fil conducteur de notre
panel disons que c'était un peu naïf du
côté de la haute fonction publique que
de pensée qui est accordé un contrat à
une entreprise qui appartient en partie
à une entreprise chinoise qui d'ailleurs
ne peut plus faire affaire avec les
États-Unis depuis maintenant 3 ans parce
qu'elle est soupçonnée d'avoir
d'être un relais du gouvernement chinois
de donner à cette entreprise-là un
contrat de la GRC alors qu'on avait une
entreprise 100% canadienne de
Boucherville que soumissionné 60000
dollars en dessous pour 60000 dollars je
trouve qu'on s'attire beaucoup de
critiques et de boss inutiles du côté de
ceux qui ont donné le contrat et avec
raison on entend parler de la stratégie
Indo-Pacifique il faut contourner la
Chine qui est une puissance
perturbatrice Saint-Jean peut-être dans
les élections canadiennes elle a des
postes de police clandestin un peu
partout dans le monde notamment il y en
aurait autour de 5 ou 6 au Canada puis
vous avez des fonctionnaires qui ont dû
dans une bulle ont jamais entendu parler
de ça ils se disent ben pour 60 000
dollars je peux le donner une entreprise
qui fait à faire avec qui est
propriétaire en partie d'une compagnie
chinoise assez difficile à comprendre je
peux comprendre le gouvernement d'être
un peu désarçonné par
ouais mais en même temps je vais me
donner une autre hypothèse le bureau du
premier ministre qui contrôle beaucoup
de choses au Canada plus que dans la
plupart des démocraties le concentration
du pouvoir et il s'est installé une
culture de pas faire d'erreur chez des
fonctionnaires des hauts fonctionnaires
plus la règle c'est le plus beau
soumissionnaire on suit aveuglement les
règles pour pas se faire chicaner donc
c'est comme si on a perdu le gros bon
sang parfois comme la toast ça rejoint
la tôle mais c'est la c'est de suivre
aveuglement les règles Jonathan
c'est vraiment je vous fais une
confidence là c'est très rare que quand
je lis un texte tout seul à mon
ordinateur dans mon bureau je parle à
mon ordinateur et en lisant le texte de
Margot je m'inquiète qualificatif c'est
révoltant c'est frustrant c'est chacun
et surtout c'est gênant j'arrêtais pas
de repasser à une expression
république bananière c'est la
l'expression qui a été employée par la
disparition fuiren dans le cadre de la
commission d'enquête sur la Loi sur les
mesures d'urgence où il disait il y a
des gens aux États-Unis qui nous
regardent aller et qui disait on a
l'impression de faire affaire avec une
république bananière or je m'excuse mais
plus que jamais cette crainte là cette
question-là elle se pose quand on pense
que dès 2017 il y a une compagnie comme
Motorola qui a dit oh on peut faire
affaire avec cette compagnie là il y a
trop de risques elle est passée sous les
mains d'une compagnie chinoise à
l'intérieur de laquelle il y a une
participation de 10% de l'État chinois
soustent en 2017 les États-Unis
l'inscrivent sur la liste des
entreprises qui peuvent représenter un
risque pour la sécurité national et nous
en 2021 sous prétexte qu'il faut
respecter le principe du plus bas
soumissionnaire on va donner un contrat
cette compagnie là pour assurer la
sécurité des communications la GRC ça ne
s'invente pas c'est
faux l'expliquer parce que à moins que
ça soit quelqu'un vraiment comme vous
disiez Alex et déconnecter de
l'actualité mais l'explication c'est de
suivre aveuglement la règle du plus bas
soumissionnaire de peur de se faire
gronder avec elle elle est où l'autre
explication parce que 100% chinois cette
entreprise là en passant oui il y a 10%
de l'État mais lors
je le sais pas je la connais pas
l'explication pas très ça peut être ça
ça peut être des fonctionnaires qui
suivent les règles à la lettre comme on
n'a pas le droit de manger une sauce au
beurre de pin-up dans un CHSLD car ça
nous appartient pas ça peut être
quelqu'un qui l'a complètement échappé
mais généralement il y a des gens qui
revisent ces dossiers là surtout
lorsqu'on vit une question de la GRC la
défense nationale du CRS c'est des
contrats ben c'est des contrats qui sont
très délicats à accorder je m'explique
pas pourquoi on l'a accordé ce contrôle
je ne sais pas un mot il reste presque
plus de temps mais monsieur Drainville
parce que la vérification générale à
Québec dit on peut pas mesurer le le
retard accumulé compte tenu de la
pandémie l'école à distance qui a mal
fonctionnait etc en même temps il dit je
voudrais bien mais j'ai pas les données
on revient à l'un au à la circulation
des données Jonathan là
ça c'est un autre élément que je ne
comprends pas à quel point le
gouvernement du Québec on a de la misère
à savoir à quoi on a affaire à
l'intérieur de notre propre de notre
propre shop si on veut là je suis le
Martin Coiteux ancien président du
Conseil du Trésor je suis parti libéral
ça lui avait pris des mois avant la
réponse à la question mais il y a
combien d'employés qui travaillent pour
la fonction publique on ne savait même
pas ça or on se rend compte que
l'éducation on manque de données on met
de l'avant des programmes sans trop
savoir finalement
l'ampleur du besoin et ça fait en sorte
qu'on y voit un peu à tâtons avec des
demi-mesures dont on a aucune garantie
d'efficacité dans l'ordreville a
beaucoup de travail à faire pour dompter
cette cette machine là on va dire comme
ça
attendez-vous à ce que Bernard
dreainville essaie de faire ce que
Christian Dubé a fait en santé avec
probablement une réforme pour obtenir
davantage de données des projets de loi
peut-être des réglementations parce que
les données là sont dans les centres de
service scolaire et ça remonte pas
facilement au ministère de la
l'éducation alors moi je pense qu'il
faut aussi donner un coup de barre pour
avoir un meilleur tableau de bord pour
reprendre le terme de Christian Dubé du
côté de l'éducation comme on est en
train de le faire pour la santé puis moi
je vais offrir mes services pour aller
vendre un coup une heure par jour
d'éducation physique à tous les élèves
du Québec pour les 15 prochaines années
merci beaucoup
messieurs bonne soirée à très bientôt au
revoir